I have some exciting news.
Is everybody ready?
Okay. So women's wear Daily,
just announced a brand new lifestyle magazine
that will hit shelves on June 14th.
And guess what it's called?
(audience murmuring)
Its called Drew!
(audience applaud)
Yap. That's it.
It's just Drew. That's it.
And listen,
I, this has been my dream,
honestly since I was a pre teenager,
ripping out tear sheets from every magazine imaginable
to create my very own wallpaper of imagery.
Look that's me at 12 years old.
Why I'm holding barbells?
I don't know. (audience laughs)
But if you take a look
at the wall behind me, my floor to ceiling,
wall to wall was nothing but tear sheets.
Magazines have just been really important to me.
And our magazine will cover some
of the things we talk about here on the show.
And more beauty, food, travel, inspiring stories and people.
And of course, news, and I hope this little collection
of pages brings you joy
and provides some escape from everyday life.
Maybe a little how to get into everyday life
at the same time.
And help us see beauty, everywhere that we look.
And the first issue will drop nationally in newsstands.
That's right, baby.
This is all paper. (audience applaud)
There'll be a digital landing page,
if you wanna look, it's a few images
it'll give you a little whiff of what we're doing
but I'm kicking it old school.
Because magazines have been
one of the greatest influences in my life.
And the fact that I can look back
on my 12 year old self and tell her that she's the founder
of a new magazine is such a good feeling. (Audience applaud)
And it's just very full circle. (applaud continues)
And I'm so excited, I can't wait to share it with you
everything I do is about putting it out there.
We have to create it, but it's not for us.
It's to put out.
(upbeat music)